let's turn now to a story about two
women making history at sports highest
level on this International women's day
Kim Ange and Caroline O'Connor are
Executives with baseball's Miami Marlins
this is the first time any major men's
franchise has had women serving as
general manager and president at the
same time CBS Saturday morning co-host
Dana Jacobson caught up with the duo as
the new season was getting started at
spring training
a familiar sight in America's pastime
but at this batting practice there's
something new these young girls young
women who see us I think it's really
inspirational for them and I think it
shows them that sky's the limit Miami
Marlins GM Kim Ang and president of
business operations Caroline O'Connor
shattering a glass ceiling in sports
together everybody wants to win there's
no doubt that comes first I know that
but diversity must matter to people
outgoing as well it does it matters you
know it it's a kind of brand that people
want to be associated with two women
leading both the business and sports
side of a major men's franchise for the
first time in history I firmly believe
the reason Kim and I are here is because
we're both very hard workers and that's
our tendency
they're part of an industry that lags
others in gender representation a 2022
report which gave Major League Baseball
a c-plus for gender hiring shown women
held less than a third of League's
central office jobs but overall last
season saw improvements with 33 women in
major and minor league coaching roles
the most in history Aang now in her
third season as general manager knows
representation matters prior to my
getting here they had three women apply
for analytics internship out of 300.
after I was hired that next year it went
up to 30. would we be here if not for
Title IX not my line not at all but it
had to happen things like that have to
happen in order for there to be change
the opening game of the World Series and
when changing a game as old as baseball
there can be growing pains
when a woman's in charge versus when a
man's in charge
yeah the leader takes a lot more crap
it just takes longer right I think for a
woman as a leader you're right to earn
the respect that a lot of times for a
guy is just giving
O'Connor a multi-sport athlete in high
school came from a business background
and joined the Marlins in 2017. she Rose
through the ranks and last year became
just the second woman to serve as
president of a Major League team do you
ever look around at your office though
and think what a unique opportunity this
is for a business person every day
baseball has been a part of Aang since
she was a kid when you were playing
stickball were you the only girl out
there playing with the boys I was I was
undoubtedly a college softball player at
the University of Chicago she got her
start in the big leagues as a 21 year
old intern for the White Sox she would
go on to hold front office jobs for the
Yankees and Dodgers
and after 15 years of applying for the
job of general manager the Marlins
finally gave Aang her shot everyone at
the time of year hiring talked about how
not just qualified you were
but overly qualified at that point you
were for the position I think that
mattered if you were going to be the
first no I definitely paid my dues yeah
for sure you know should I have gotten
the job earlier perhaps yeah it's just
the luck of the draw sometimes right and
and that's that's life
do you feel it more
because we carry it for women also yeah
I definitely feel that pressure you know
when I read letters each day from young
women or young girls
um you know you just keep thinking that
you can't fail it's really important to
hear those stories talk to people have
people see us in our roles as much as
possible so you know if the little kids
can see themselves here and ultimately
for Aang and O'Connor it's about being
part of the team Joe Torre was talking
about you and he said she's just one of
us
how important is that when you're
working in an organization it's
immensely important yeah I think it's
it's you know it says a lot about being
one of the team and you know you're
willing to roll your sleeves up like
anybody else you're willing to get dirty
like anybody else you will fight that
fight with them every day for CBS
mornings Dana Jacobson Jupiter Florida
I love them putting the Marlins in a
position to win as well 15 years she
applied for that job 15 years
congratulations they're both doing
exactly where they need to be at the
very right time bravo bravo